jeanne est devenu tétraplégique à la
suite d'un accident depuis le 15
décembre 2021 elle n'a plus de
sensations de la poitrine jusqu'aux
orteils même si mes bras bougent quand
même très bien mais et mes doigts sont
que du spaghettis en ce moment l'an
passé la Docteur Dominique Tremblay lui
a proposé quelque chose d'incroyable
réanimer les muscles de ses mains c'est
vraiment ça l'espace de changer de
terminologie de dire j'ai l'usage de mes
bras je suis plus un tétraplégique je
suis un paraplégique on leur demande
qu'est-ce qui aimerait le plus améliorer
au quotidien c'est vraiment la fonction
de leurs mains pour leur permettre
d'être plus indépendant essentiellement
Montréal le 28 juillet 2022 équipes une
pour chaque main
9 heures de chirurgie pour que l'influx
nerveux circulent à nouveau jusqu'à ses
mains on a redirigé des nerfs sains vers
des nerfs inactifs l'influx nerveux
essentiellement c'est comme le courant
électrique c'est on va changer le
circuit d'influx nerveux vers un qui
fonctionne à un qui ne fonctionne pas
puis là en refaisant la connexion avec
le temps tout ça va se régénérer et
refonctionner même si sa dextérité ne
sera jamais comme avant les attentes
sont grandes
les trois mouvements qu'on espère
redonner à Jeanne c'est l'extension
poignet droit pousse et pince et plus de
force de flexion des doigts personne ne
dit que l'opération serait miraculeuse
on pense pas que je vais pouvoir écrire
avec les dix doigts mais peut-être avec
deux doigts beaucoup plus précis une
fois la connexion nerveuse effectuée il
faudra patienter deux ans le temps que
la régénérescence des nerfs soit
complétée et que le cerveau s'adapte aux
nouveaux circuit nerveux
durant la phase expérimentale une
dizaine de patients ont subi cette
intervention les résultats se sont
révélés ici encourageant que l'hôpital
maison neuve-rosemont offre maintenant
le transfert de nerfs à certains
patients est-ce que tout le monde est un
bon candidat non la réponse sinon l'âge
est un peu un limitant parce qu'on sait
que la régénérescence se fait mieux
quand on est plus jeune puis des fois on
a des candidats qui ont
malheureusement une maison trop haute et
nous manque des bons muscles à pouvoir
dire j'en prends de lui pour redonner
ailleurs six mois après le transfert de
nerf les améliorations sont déjà
remarquables c'est juste que ma parade
ici soit la moins paradisante possible
mais je trouve que j'y arrive toujours
un jour
recouvrez l'usage de ses mains le rêve
deviendra réalité ici Dany Lemieux
Radio-Canada Montréal